a record-breaking 22 million comments
have been filed with the FCC on its
process to restore Internet freedom the
so called title to net neutrality docket
what does this number mean well as a
matter of policy not much FCC
commissioners are politically appointed
and are supposed to be outside of
influence of others as a matter of
procedure the FCC has to allow for
public comment but these comments should
not be confused with votes and even if
they were they'd be dramatically skewed
in favor of the digital elite not truly
reflective of the will of the people
data shows that net neutrality advocacy
is driven largely by males age 21 to 34
who aren't at least seventy six thousand
dollars a year these digital elites can
afford to intellectualize their
preferences and impose them on others
but for underprivileged persons
these rules perpetuate the digital
divide rather than digital elites
dictating how the Internet should be
Internet freedom is about empowering
individuals the poor the old and people
of color to get online quickly easily
and at the lowest cost that's why we
should support Internet freedom to learn
more about my take on title to net
neutrality check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI